bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
time while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right I'm here with the beautiful
and intelligent plain of Mara Nova I
have put her through hell already this
morning lots of great things I've been
doing to annoy her but she's here one of
them being he went and wet his hair and
I don't know just what you did to it but
it's like dripping water your boy got
the cut last Friday it is ready to go I
might start putting gel in it leave me a
comment let me know that they got should
gel this bad boy up in the future all
right let's get into block 5 is the new
spot so you guys thought I was going to
sponsor today but no no no it's Monday
I'm on top of my game
black Phi is the sponsor short story get
money get paid they've got three
products you can deposit crypto they'll
give you US dollar loan you can buy it
sell crypto or my favorite product I'm
an investor na user is to deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
ap why you can't get that anywhere else
plenty here's me brag about block five
pretty much every single day hey anybody
who helps me get rich I'm into it let's
get a less money right block fine go
check them out click on the link in the
description what can I tell the people
what you put me is here this morning now
let's do a couple of news stories first
and then we can talk about my
intelligence what's called the
unemployment error there was a Mis
classification error made in the that
made the main unemployment rate look
better than it actually was
so they reported major air 13 points
something percent unemployment which
meant that there was a 2.5 million jobs
created in May but wait whoops
we don't know how to count instead the
actual unemployment rate is closer to 17
percent it's 16 point whatever percent
300 basis points higher why because they
can't count but the best part is they
literally put in a support saying that
they were wrong basically they like miss
the furloughed people right
yeah we're just not gonna count the one
the people who are unemployed you know
will make the number look better than it
actually is don't forget people stay
educated pay attention it's all a sham
there's tens of millions of people
without work they can make it seem like
things are getting better look outside
doesn't look better than me what's going
on Palantir so Palantir you may know it
as Peter Thiel secretive kind of data
defense I don't even know what they do
they're just like a very similar data
analytics company so the UK government
gave Palantir access to sensitive
medical records of Koba 19 patients in
do you know how much they give it won't
you decide for one pound one euro is it
a pound or your that's a pound the the
pound signal looks weird symbol not
signal symbol yeah look I don't know
what's going on here but anytime that
you see a transaction where they're
sensitive medical data being handed over
for literally not a million not not a
billion not a hundred pounds one pound
because the data includes personal
contact details gender race occupation
physical and mental health conditions
past criminal offenses as well as
religious and political affiliation I
was feeling this is something for like a
tracing contact tracing situation yeah
this doesn't look all the details are
not out this recently was published on
an open democracy type website where
they try to publish the information that
they see in these government contracts
and things like that what I will say is
huge win for the open source open data
type movement because they basically are
exposing this this doesn't look so great
on the British government because they
seem to just be handing over all the day
that I I don't think that's right also
what is my packet or what is my if I'm a
Kovac patient what is my past criminal
record have to do with me being well I
agree with you and I think he said not
right
I was wrong but like this is wrong yeah
so I think we're both on the same page
like they shouldn't be doing this
my guess though is that what a data
analytics firm wants to do is give me as
much data as you possibly can and then
I'll sift through all those variables
and try to find interesting kind of
tidbits in the data so what they
probably are asking for is give me every
piece of public information that you
have on this individual plus all of
their health data so one of the
databases where you would get public
information on somebody is their
criminal background how is it possible
that the government can just sell that
data to a private American company well
whose customers include the FBI the CIA
the US Army so two of the things that I
think are interesting is one I'm not as
familiar with the UK and kind of what
their their standards are so in the
United States there's all kinds of
health privacy type things in place I'm
assuming that there's those in the UK
but that would be one question I have
and the second thing that is somewhat
concerning is are these people aware
that their data has been sold right so
if all of a sudden well if all of a
sudden you said to me hey one there's
not as many privacy concerns or privacy
kind of barriers in place and to every
single one of these patients somewhere
signed to agree to do this that's a
different story I do not believe that's
what happened here Yeah right I think
that this was actually done kind of more
covertly but obviously it's been exposed
and then just super super shady when any
transaction is done for one dollar or
one pound so it's basically free but
yeah this isn't good I mean look we all
kind of know that this is happening the
infringement on our privacy on our civil
liberties in times of crisis that's what
happens what better thing to do than say
hey give me all this information and
I'll try to help you prevent the next
outbreak or I'll try to help you curve
this outbreak you know just kind of very
very very scary world but I'm glad that
open-source type data information got it
out there it's pretty good alright let's
go on disband the plate this is this is
my favorite story right now
okay in a historic move the Minneapolis
City Council has pledged to disband the
city's police department and replace it
with a new system of Public Safety so
that's interesting
first of all what's the difference
between I'm seeing a lot of disband
versus defund what's the difference uh
again I'm not an expert on law
enforcement funding but the main issue
here is look there are massive protests
going on right now over two things
racism and police brutality they're
interconnected we don't have to go to
the details you guys are kind of aware
of that there are many movements of what
to do now so it's hey we've identified a
problem how do we solve that problem one
of the solutions is do nothing that
doesn't seem like a very popular one
another solution is to defund which
basically means to take away some of the
funding so you're not breaking up the
police
you're not saying we're not gonna give
you zero dollars but in New York City
for example I think the budget for
either twenty twenty one or twenty
twenty was six billion dollars for the
police if all of a sudden I believe de
Blasio has already said that he's gonna
take a billion dollars away so now they
have five billion rather than six
billion right so more than a little less
than twenty percent is gonna get taken
away the idea is if they have less
budget then they can't go buy all of the
toys right they can't go buy the tanks
and all this crazy stuff that they keep
these tanks oh and warehouses and on the
street like literally parking on the
street sometimes city well you're
thinking of like an tank with the track
these are like mine-resistant armored
vehicles or clawhammer apps but but the
whole idea is if they have less money
then they can buy less weapons and gear
and all that kind of stuff so that's
kind of defunding the police at the most
watered-down version there are some
people who actually believe hey we
should just cut most of the funding so
like not 15% but that's just like 90%
and then there's the people who go the
farthest who say let's disband the place
literally let's say we have a police
department we're gonna fire everybody
we're gonna get rid of the police the
Minneapolis City Council has actually
voted to go do this which is wild they
wanted to get rid of the police
department they do have a plan and I put
that in air quotes to come up with a
Public Safety
type thing my guess is what they're
gonna say is like hey if you call 9-1-1
there's the first group of people who
respond to something come without guns
mm-hmm right they're there to
de-escalate situations to act more as
like a referee than they are to show up
with guns and all the weaponry then if
you need kind of people show up with
guns then there's some ability to get to
that but it's more about like the
rehabilitation of the community more
about public service what do you think
about this before I say what I think
well okay obviously I am NOT a fan of
disband are completely abolishing the
police department because what are you
gonna do in situations of domestic abuse
theft robbery all that stuff that we
need police for but I I could be in
favor of reforming it in some way and
coming up so I I was trying to find it
but anyway I read this article about
Camden New Jersey I believe it was and
how in the last seven years they've kind
of completely restructured their police
force and the police brutality
complaints or calls cases have gone down
ninety five percent so I thought that
was interesting
so one you're dead on if you want to
disband the police
you better be singing the praises of the
Second Amendment from the tops of
mountains because either you call people
with guns or you have a gun to defend
yourself there's no in-between we do not
want to live in a world where people
don't own weapons and you can't call
anybody to show up with a weapon because
like you said domestic abuse any sort of
violence robbery all that kind of stuff
because it's a criminals like dream all
of a sudden the people don't can't
defend themselves and they can't call
anyone to defend themselves for that
like what of course there's gonna be a
lot of crime what you're talking about
is police reform which is they didn't
take away funding in many cases they
didn't disband the police instead they
changed it so these are rules around
they say something like 50 percent of
the plea and I'm making this up but just
directly this is correct fifty percent
of the police force
to live in the districts that they
police so if let's take Manhattan for
example if you are going to be a police
officer in the Bronx over 50% of the
people policing the Bronx have to live
in the Bronx and the idea is well the
idea is like your policing your
community right these are the people you
live among this is not hey I live in you
know the Upper East Side of Manhattan
and then oh for work I go to the Bronx
and like I can treat those people
differently than the people I would
treat in my local could be that may get
more of like a community feeling you
know the people they're your neighbors
of course so like that's one piece of
police reform a second piece of police
reform which again there's a lot of
debate on the efficacy of this was to
put body cameras on police officers so
there's a bunch of studies that show the
body cameras don't actually lead to less
police brutality there's questions as to
whether officers are actually turning
them on or not whatever but like there's
all kinds of things you can do to reform
but the biggest reform and it's becoming
quite clear I think in the data is the
police unions like there are example
after example after example where a
police officer has somebody file a
complaint around police brutality that
complaint the officer is disciplined in
some form or fashion whether it's
they're fine and they're suspended
they're fired whatever the police union
steps in and says you can't do that and
they become incredibly aggressive and
how to get that officer reinstated and
so it's kind of like the people who are
the bad apples or actually the ones that
the police unions protect the most regs
they don't need to step in and protect
the good guys they step in and protect
the guys who are getting fired and
suspended in LA stuff last thing I'll
say about this did you hear what
happened in Minneapolis when there was a
representative I forget if he was a city
council member or something else he
wanted to I think it was just police
reform I don't think I actually wanted
to disband the police but he wanted to
reform the police and all of a sudden he
started get reports that from his
constituents that when they would call
9-1-1 the police would take forever to
get there and they would ask the police
yo what's going on why are you thinking
so long they say go ask your
representative so they were
intentionally slowing their response to
the constituents of a specific district
because they didn't agree with the
reform policies of the
the representative that's not cool yeah
that's not cool I will say though you
know I think for years there's been a
lot of journalism done and in-depth
article on investigative articles etc
and no real reform not no changes have
happened but in the wake of all the
protests I mean people are they're
disbanding the police like there's real
material changes happening and do you
think that's because just of the of the
uproar of the peoples well so we should
be clear I believe and again this is all
kind of a moving target because
happening so quickly I believe that the
mayor of Minneapolis has stepped up and
said he's rejecting this proposal from
the Minneapolis City Council so he's
kind of its kind of like a veto power it
sounds like so he's actually saying no
we are not gonna disband the police
we'll see how it plays out that's that's
something that just got reported the
second thing to your point is there are
reports again and I was looking this one
I confirm it that the Chief of Police
and like his second-in-command in New
York City the NYPD is stepping down both
the chief of police at the
second-in-command are gonna step down
and 300 to 800 police officers on the
NYPD
or going to seek early retirement like
almost immediately and basically what
happens is like look there's no winners
in this right the people feel like the
police brutality is there's racism
there's targeting there's all these
things by the way look at the videos
like the police are literally beating
unarmed citizens in the streets you can
say that there's a reason for them to do
it or not but that's what's happening
right and then from the police officers
a lot of them feel like they're in a
impossible situation right they're like
look like we're trying to do our jobs we
just want to keep our community safe and
go home but again they feel like the
media has it out for them they feel like
people are targeting them now and so you
get two groups they're diabolically
opposed to each other they're in
conflict and now you get police officers
you're just gonna say look this is not
worth this job anymore right and so
ultimately what we see is look protests
lead to change not always I I don't I
think there have been protests before
but they haven't been this effective so
we can argue on how effective but in
many cases there is change
you can argue as was it the right type
of change right so why Camden police for
example they made changes so might not
happen on a national level but in
certain communities it happens and then
the second thing and this is the crazier
part is I continue to say the number one
thing that the protesters should do
right the protest in general across the
country is they should come forward with
very specific asks so saying hey we want
justice right justice is so hard to say
did we disband the police again those
are such big leaps that there's a lot of
things you can ask for from here to
there so there are some proposals that
I've seen like there's like these eight
steps and I forget the name of exactly
what it is but there's eight specific
asks of the police of what people should
do to me that is much better because you
really negotiate using the protest as a
negotiating tool with the state right or
in the state being the government so if
you come to the table with specific asks
then you have a point of leverage say I
want you to reduce the police budget by
30 percent and I want you to commit to
having 50 percent of officers live in
their district and I want you to commit
to no longer taking weapons of war and
putting them on I think that it started
with outrage in in anger and frustration
and then as it evolves I think people
will come together and figure out
exactly what they want completely agree
and I think that we're actually headed
that way and I think that we will get
solutions out of this the question is
how big are those improvements and also
how effective are they but but I do not
think that there is going to be a
national movement to disband the police
across communities like I just think
that's kind of outside the bounds of
what's gonna happen all right agreed yes
nice bing-bang just just wait till I
tell you what he did this morning go
ahead starship rocks so starship Elon
Musk is telling how SpaceX employees
then its starship rocket is his top
priority now and so if you don't know
the starship rocket aims to be fully
reusable and launch as many as 100
people at a time on missions to the Moon
and Mars guess who I will be launching
to the moon the
first opportunity I have to do so me
I'll go I don't care see ya
this is cool because any most other
people they just launched to humans to
space they would be celebrating they
would be all stuff Elance already on to
the next thing cool we figured out how
to do that we're gonna have to continue
to do that do that well but at the same
time let's figure out this next rocket
much bigger and can launch 100-plus
people do you think that Richard Branson
is kind of watching from afar like oh I
think Richard Branson and Jeff Bezos
both fun fact I once interviewed Richard
Branson and asked him about Elon Musk
and he said he feels like he's like his
little brother like he sees him a
younger version of himself in him he
weighed Richard Branson things that Elon
Musk is his little brother like he
seasoned like a younger version of his
well evil on musk is like hey dude I got
a figure cool pity so I'm like maybe you
should step your game up so yeah so what
do you think this like I think this is
smart
of course it's smart it's fully reusable
it can launch as many as a hundred
people it could be used over and over
again and it's supposed to bring people
to the moon into Mars okay when is he
gonna be able to launch 100 people to
the moon well he just launched - so he's
2% no but he could he could have gone to
the moon right listen anybody who bets
against Elon Musk is dumb right and and
I understand all the arguments against
some of the companies and stuff like
that but like the man and his team right
because it's not just him it's his team
continue to innovate at ASA a rate that
we just aren't seeing for other
companies so like I'm long Elon Musk
would you rather go to the moon or to
Mars I'd rather go to Mars really yeah
there's nothing there
that's not true I just saw a photo of a
volcano that has ice water on it and
musk even tweeted and said there's
actually a lot of ice water on Mars just
saying speaking of let's go to Joe
exotic what's going on there Joe exotic
is not doing well in prison I really
thought that shocker no but I really
thought he would be he wasn't doing well
in society either yeah but once he saw
the like that Carroll Baskins husband's
will was likely forged I thought he'd
feel a little bit know he's in prison
everyone
nobody cares about other people's
problems I like
about the room so Joe exotic wrote this
letter that's kind of disturbing saying
that he's at the end of his rope and
might not be around much longer if he
doesn't get some immediate help from
President Trump cardi B or Kim
Kardashian he really knows who to call
man yeah he's really recently due his
bag of tricks trying to do whatever he
possibly can saying my soul is dead he's
saying allegedly that he's not getting
the treatment and meant for his health
conditions that he needs in prison doing
his husband or ex-husband is out
partying and he's not allowed to
participate well it's cuz I read the
internet everyone knows that's where I
get my information from and yeah that's
exactly what he said oh I'd be so mad if
I was in prison and you were out
partying oh lord have mercy I said oh
I'd be sending you Instagram DM saying
look at this cool thing that I'm doing I
wouldn't have Instagram cuz I'd be in
prison well they'll just rack up until
you get out when you get out you can
just see a whole timeline of all the fun
I had while you were going okay let's do
the lunch money win it then you can tell
your story I did some epic stuff today
guys this morning was it awesome the
lunch money winner is Rhian day what I
think yeah or racer 15 some reason 1578
said so who is Rowan Atkinson I asked
who would play you in a movie
do we know who wrote do you not know you
picked the winner and don't even know oh
he was mr. bean Oh mr. bean what a great
guy
mr. Meighan did he get in trouble for
child pornography just take that in real
quick I know I just got planted a type
in child pornography on Google so he
says man I just like to make people
laugh
thanks for the show never miss an
episode I apologize written for doing
your ads that you're gonna track a
warning I got like
thing yelled at me listen I'm gonna send
over a hundred bucks I appreciate you
guys doing that we had a great laugh at
all the different tweets go ahead and
tell your story to wrap this up we were
here out of time go ahead okay so this
morning they don't need to know what we
were doing just tell them we were
talking to somebody in the city
government the profile shirt on try when
someone we were zooming with somebody in
City Hall in New York City it was for a
marriage license okay god we're trying
to get our marriage license that we've
been trying to get for months now
successfully got it today so the lady is
like okay I just need to ask you some
questions
Paulina have you ever been previously
married I said no ma'am I have not and
then they asked her friend over here if
he's been previously married and what
did you say I said I only been married
to the game but I guess that don't
really count here I think she asked me
about a hundred times like if I was sure
and then the best part is I knew that
point I was really upset with me because
she literally punched me under the table
in my leg so at the very end of the call
I then said to the woman hey you've been
so kind to us would you mind giving us a
rating as feedback like a grade on our
performance today on this call with you
you know a to D a being the easiest to
work with D being the worst and she gave
us an A and so now planet can't complain
because I could say well listen the lady
thought that we were super easy to work
with she gave us at eighth grade so why
would you grade me differently than she
would and we got off that call and did I
grade you that's it for today guys your
boy is still alive hanging out got a
haircut
I should be an actor all right while
Wall Street's trying to get rich the
best of us just trying to get our lunch
money right we'll see you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money's now sponsored
by block five so go check them out
there's a link in the description that
you can click on I'm an investor a user
and a huge fan what you're a bigger fan
of block fire than your army block wise
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina they've got 3 products
they can give you a u.s. dollar loan
can earn up to 8.6 percent interest on
an interest-bearing account or you can
buy and sell cryptocurrencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
8.6 percent interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account go do your own
research there's risk associated but 8.6
percent it's pretty compelling so click
on the link in the description say
thanks to the folks that block buy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy plan in the comment and we'll see
you guys tomorrow and be kind to your
friends